hi guys Lucy here with a pc centric
gamespot news update for you click rates
Justin Timberlake once asked what's
better than 10 million active accounts
the answer of course is 100 million
active accounts I may be paraphrasing
but that's the milestone that steam has
just hit this new figure is up by 25
million from the 75 million figure
announced in January in that time we've
had pro cycling manager season 2014
litter de france which easily explains
the massive jumping numbers valve also
announced that there are now more than
3,700 games on Steam with more than 1300
games added in 2014 alone this time last
year only 304 titles were added to steam
in the first nine months of the year
that sound you hear is my wallet crying
ahead of the next sale vile revealed the
figure today as part of a wider
announcement of the major steam
discovery update which introduces a
range of new features and functionality
aimed at helping you filter through the
flood of new releases the new homepage
is smarter offering personalized
recommendations based on your gameplay
they'll also be new search and discovery
tools and the ability to filter out
titles you already own or just aren't
interested in like pro cycling manager
season 2013 steam will also support
curators individuals or groups you post
recommendations online you can follow
these curators to keep up with their
tips and rate their reviews valve has
said that the update comes as a direct
result of its conversations with
developers publishers and customers but
what do you make of it all how many
unplayed games are in your Steam library
two reviews the reviewers let me know in
the comments for all the latest pro
cycling manager season 2014 loco de
France news stay tuned here to gamespot
you